لكنني لست عجوزًا ، أنا فقط أعيش وقتًا طويلاً
لكن ربما لن أفعل ذلك على أي حال ، أنا معجب بها
نحن بحاجة إلى أن نكون في الوقت المناسب لهذه الجدة السابعة ، ولكن كيف أنا
سأحصل على أيام ، ولهذا السبب لم تكن هناك إجابة واحدة
أريد أن أرى حفلة مشاركة الجدة
ما يصل إلى 9 ثم كل شيء
إذا كنا نعيش هناك لعيد ميلاد نحن
نعيش هناك غارقين في البقية وهم
نعيش هنا هذه المضخة عطلة ياروسلاف
بالنسبة إلى الترباس الإلكتروني ، فهو ماضٍ خالد
بقلم بيبي جيم جيت بلاك ليفين
التخفيف 1 هو عبارة عن فطيرة دجاج أو فيميو
وبو أودي a1 ها هو
[موسيقى]
مديري هو إيطاليا وسويوز دودو لهذا اليوم
الى ابعد حد
وحيدون تركيبة اذن اطفال دايم وايل
كولين
wimey مع أقمارهم ليست الأقمار الصناعية التي
تحفيز طفل في المنزل من هذا العلم
حديقة
أوليا للتسوق وبالتالي لديك تقويم
على جلطة على الأقل ميدالية من
بيتروبافلوفسك-كامتشاتسكي أنا kutya urale
بولينتا الأثير عليك ديك طفل قاتمة
لا يزال ياروسلاف ليتا فيليه من اندفاعة الألم
ثم سترسل إلينا Bleach إلى جميع الـ 11
الجنة الهندوسية وبندر الهراء له
سابقا
ناديجدا بابكينا وحتى الخام لهدف
سبحان الله يحفظ المخيفين
نعم ، عاش جبين uti-mata 100 عام
ياروسلاف مستاء
إنها كرمل أحادي ثم بأي شكل
صيدا ايلينا
ذهبت إلى موقع بحثت في منزل مجاني
كان مجرد قائد اتضح أنه هو
مجانا لدينا للجميع
الظروف كان لدي مثل هذا
فكرة
لقد أنشأت الموقع وأصله
ذهب بشكل طبيعي إلى
أنا أعيش في منطقة بحث الشبكة
وذهبت جمهورية القرم من خلال
اطلب من يديها من ركبتيها أن تتعبني و
نفهم أن هناك حاجة للمساعدة
التي ولكن هناك جوليا والدبابات
إيكاترينبرج آندي بالا أنطون ناشا
حرب
ثقوب بدون مجرفة وبطريقة ما الأسود
أصلي حيث مكياج نامي جين آل
mamlyaka تحرق الطريق بعد الهدية الترويجية Lkm
طلب بهاء العصيدة ، وأنا أغرق طعام آسيا
ريتش مان 8 من لوس ألتوس مجرد موضوع
فيلم Schlegel سر رحمتوفا اثنان
[موسيقى]
بارك الله فيك بالصحة والعافية
شكرا لك أيها اللطيف دعنا نخرج في هذا العالم
فخورون بمزيد من النفوس
أحسنت في هذه المعجزة نوع من بركة
إنهائه
الصندوق دائما غارق في العواطف القط
[موسيقى]
ذرة البطل إصلاح 10 20 لم يكن كذلك
صعبة
دائما مثل نوع من الدفء في الروح وهذا
رائع جدا أنا لا أعرف من لدي بسيف
لذلك فهو يشبه شكل الحجر
حيث كان هذا المشروع لي لفترة طويلة
رئيس ، ولكن من أجل البدء في ذلك ، لا بد من المدعي
المال وادخار واحد لهذا التسريب
المال هنا وهذا هو الفودكا من لي
ضرب و
لقد رأيت مرات عديدة كيف نواب و
جاء المسؤولون لمثل هؤلاء الناس مع
الزهور مع التهنئة بالبطاقات البريدية
أعطاه
جو مهيب ولكن هؤلاء الناس
لفترة طويلة جدًا لم يكن هناك إصلاح ولا أحد
لن يأتي ولا يصل إلى 100
نسبه مئويه
لذلك فعلت مشروعي و
التسريح على الواقع موريتي ايلينا
وعد شجرة النخيل أنا
ساحة المعركة على طولنا الصورة anakin و joule
تان مثل تلك الموجودة في نادي موسكو
أحرقت في الفيلم على الرغم من هذه الحقيقة هي هي
فيكتوريا سواء داريا فيدوروفا للطفل في المنزل
يا أبي دعاء دافي أكثر فندق
يتحمل
مرحبا اريد قصة شعر
افعل كما في الصورة التي يتحولون إليها
أدى 3 ottinger غادر الفيلم
عش في ذلك العمر
حاشا الله للجميع أن يعيشوا لعمري
هذه هي ابنتي يساعد أ
ثم سوف تتغير
اذهب للراحة لمدة نصف ساعة على ما أعتقد
ماذا لو حلم
ثم حلم ، إذا كان الشيء من نوع ما ، فهو كذلك
نفس
كما لو كان الأمر بسيطًا وأنت تستخدمه وهذا كل شيء
هنا في الذاكرة سوف تتذكر طويلا
أعتقد أن صديقاتي سوف يتفاخرن
احبه دايت مارك 1 × دوناتي ليسيا
ميدان لأم موساتوف هي حارسة الأسد
عرفات عريضه
بصراحة ، لم نصدق ذلك حقًا
سوف يتحقق الحلم بسرعة
تطوع في موسكو وجاهز للوفاء
حلم
حتى وإن كان في شكل مختلف حلم سنوات الحمام
مما نطرزه وبالطبع تتطابق مع الفرح
متفق عليه
عندما تكون في مزاج ثم تخرج من المخالب
لا أفعل له شيئاً دكاترة وخطيرة
اشخاص
[موسيقى]
Andryushka مرحبا الزعيم والمكعبات
وأرسلت لك كلبًا عن الكتاب
أنت لا تجيب بلطف يمكنك أن ترى التقرير
هو دور شريط الميزانية في تجفيف خنزير النفط
خط مفاصل ، جسم واضح يعرف متى
مريض على الكرة الجنية الغضب الأصدقاء الطحين لك
شعرت ماريا بلوف شريطي على السيوف الأوسط
وحدة محدودة لن ترضي العالمين
وكل شيء سيكون واو اكتشاف ذلك
104 سنة
حسنًا ، على الأقل لا أريد الحصول على كشوف المرتبات
لرؤية القائد بالطبع هناك و
العقل السليم تماما يفكر بوضوح
جميل للغاية
نظمت طائرة هليكوبتر طرت هناك
جاءت البهجة وسوف
حاليا
تقليديا عندما أنشأت هذا الموقع و
ابدأ مشروع سجل حصريًا على
موقع كنت أهدف إلى إنشاء أداة
صلات الناس الذين يحلمون والناس
الذين يريدون أن يفعلوا شيئًا جيدًا
قوي لمدة 150 عاما
استيفاء كل من المادية و
بفضل المعنوية الرقمية
التكنولوجيا فيه فهو كذلك
لتحقيق الأحلام
بلا مأوى على القهوة الخيول Moscu أنا ليرة و
المعركة الحقيقية ستكون من أمالاكي
اسأله وايلينا لي uglich
أمل بابكين الكبير
[موسيقى]
جثث المراقب عزفت وغنيت والآن
كدت أن ألعب معي حتى إنني لا شيء
يسمع
تم أخذ الأب على الفور في السنة الأولى ل
أمي الأمامية تركت خمسة أطفال أطفال
كان الأصغر يبلغ من العمر تسعة أشهر
كان على معظمهم المساعدة بشكل عام أنا
عملت 43 سنة
حتى أن الطفولة لم يروا الموضوعات
حذرك الطبال بالأمس أو بعد ذلك
أمس الأسود للبحث عن ليزا يمكنك ذلك
كان ذهبيًا قويًا كما أصبحت باكو
مرحباً بالانتصارات!
عندما بدأت الحرب ذهبت إلى الصف الثالث
فرقعة من هذه الصيغة لترك تاسيا لي
منازل
تحت والدجاج متزوج أنا لست gk-1 fbd لنا
سأكتب عناوين الأفلام
ذات مرة عرف فيلم طوبا ميل على بعد أميال
مدينة الرياح أنا
التفاصيل قبل التهاب الكبد بارع ايليا شرن وحيد
كعك عيد الفصح في السحر
coolie shyin lee لكن سيدي أنت لا تعرف ماذا
مثل هذا الغداء في الصباح كان قنفذًا للعمل
ستجد طريقًا أقل بإعطاء هذه هي الطريقة
نجوا وهم يعرفون حتى Acai إلى Galina
الاشتراك في عدد مخارج Taesh
Playbill على TNT Jules يستنزف اليوم نحن
بدء تجديد الذكرى السنوية العاشرة
جالينا الكسندروفنا لم يلاحظ قط
أعياد الميلاد ، وبالتالي ليس عندما أنا
لم يعط أحد أي شيء ، لم يكن هناك شيء
سرير المال أوه أيضا أعطانا لا
كان جديدًا والآن يريده الجميع
القواعد وتفعل شو السادس الوحوش
الأمر متروك لك أن تفعله الجماهير
تقديرك
[موسيقى]
تنظيم المشروع بأكمله الذي أشارك فيه
واحد الآن عمري 34 سنة
لا يوجد أطفال فيها ، هناك أناس
بالنظر إلى مشروعي فهم هذا
مستوحى ، لست مضطرًا لذلك
يمكن إصلاح ومساعدة الناس على القيام به
ما هو الضرر الآخر هو الشيء الرئيسي
للاستمتاع بها
كيف اقول جمال ما تضخم
يا له من شيء ، كم هو جميل كل شيء
تم الاصلاح
من الأرض إلى السقف تم وضع جميع الأثاث
من الجيد إلى الموضة الجميلة
بكيت كثيرا غادرت أمس
أنت حتى لا تعرف الفرح
[موسيقى]
استنشاق وملثم جديد لير موجودا
فيلم من الخام
حول المفتاح استمتع بهذا القبيح
أهلا وأنا أراك مرحبا
إيلينا إيفانوفنا من منزل قدامى المحاربين
الآن دعنا نحاول تحقيق حلمك
ناديجدا جورجيفنا
جلبت إلى الاستعداد هنا مرة أخرى 0
حتى منفصلة
إيلينا الحمام أنا سعيد بالتحقق من صحة لك
أعلم أن لديك رغبة في ماذا
طريقة لتكون في حفلتنا الموسيقية ولكن في
اتصال مع الوضع الحالي
فهم دا نصل إلى بعضنا البعض
ثقيل جيدا هناك اتصال
لم تكن موجودة من قبل ، ها هي
أقف على دي بابكين والفريق بأكمله
اغنية روسية
ضع في اعتبارك أن حفلة اليوم مثل هذه
خط لك مزاج جيد
الصحة والعيش طويلا لا أفتقد
tut دا دا بلدي إلى أي شيء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
أنا
[موسيقى]
إنه فقط أنني أنحني لك عند قدميك ومن أجل ذلك
أن جئت حدث على الإطلاق
معجزة
لا تنشر الكثير على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
يطلبون أن يأتي للمساعدة ولكن الجميع في الخارج للقيام به
إصلاح مستحيل
ما هو مستقبل المشروع بصدق
أقول حتى وأنا لست على ما يرام بشكل طبيعي
اريده ان ينمو
لا أعرف كيف أفعل هذا ، سيساعدني
تقرر من أجل الاستنتاج بأن كل منها قابل للقسمة بالضبط
من فوفان الرقص روسيا جدا الماوس و
أحيانًا نكون أناسًا عاديين لا يفعلون ذلك
يرتبط بالميزانية
أسهل بكثير لجمع 150 شخصًا
أداء سيكون صغيرا جدا
حلم عزيز
[موسيقى]
نعم ، إن لم يكن لهم ، فربما هذا
كانت الدولة على علم بذلك ، ولكن إذا كان الأمر كذلك
ثم بالامتنان وينبغي للوطن
تزويدهم بكل ما يحتاجون إليه
لم يشكو على الإطلاق
هم مستحقون حتى نعش الحياة
كانوا ممتنين
هل هذا المنزل راتب هل هو معاش صيفي
أي مساعدة
[موسيقى]
يشترى